I love girls I'm bisexual I'm gay I like
the wine and not the label yes coming
out is never easy but there have been
some incredible scenes that showed the
true meaning of it gets better thanks
for telling me Netflix's Heart Stopper
had audiences in happy tears with its
touching coming out scene featuring the
character of Nick Nelson and his mother
is good bisexuality
I've heard that Glee saw a string of
queer characters come out from Santana
Lopez coming out as lesbian I want you
to know me
Who I Really Am
coming out as trans I gotta get my body
in alignment with how I see myself and
Kurt coming out as gay I'm gay thanks
for telling me Kurt and while there have
been a slew of fantastic coming out
scenes from shows like sex education
Brooklyn Nine-Nine stranger things
shit's creek only murders in the
building Chucky and sex lives of college
girls
the only way you can be happy
is if you're yourself it's this
emotional scene from The Beloved Coming
of Age film love Simon that takes the
cake I'm gay you get to be more you than
you have been in
in a very long time